pois é essa é a pergunta que me fazem
sempre inclusive os meus pais e depois
de fazer graduação mestrado e doutorado
até hoje eles não sabem meu pai que tem
89 anos quando é abordado por alguém e
perguntam para ele as suas filhas em
duas uma advogada
a outra causa
peraí eu vou abrir a carteira e tem um
cartão de visita ele suelen antropólogos
bom essa é a maior dúvida q sic sic
sempre mito que fazem é quem não é da
área que me perguntam é principalmente
por causa da tradição brasileira de
concentrar ao a área de antropologia
dentro dos muros da academia
a gente não se articula muito é com as
outras áreas de conhecimento
por isso que eu acabo me considerando
uma profissional híbrida
porque na verdade eu não sou uma
antropóloga por isso o trabalho em
empresas e ajuda as pessoas a pensar
estratégias para entender melhor como as
pessoas consomem como as pessoas a
pensão lógicas de valor e eu vou contar
um pouquinho pra vocês sobre isso ea
experiência que eu tive e que está
abrindo portas a dentro do brasil para
outro ou outros profissionais então am e
é esse tipo de conhecimento aplicado
empresa como é que isso é possível
na primeira coisa de tudo é que eu
imagino que a antropologia e se a gente
for pensar na grafia antropo homem né e
ser humano e elogia a razão é estudo é o
estudo do homem ao estudo das diferenças
culturais e quando a gente fala cultura
a gente está falando de um mapa de um
código de uma de valores neder
identidades sociais
então eu entendo que a antropologia foi
justamente a aplicada nas empresas
essa união entre clientes e há as
empresas as indústrias as agências e
tudo mais então é mais como todo mundo
comumente não entendi muito bem que a
antropologia eu vou tentar dar uma
pequena explicação é e antropologia ela
começa na praia e aí vai ter lá uma foto
a navegação não antes da topologia ser
de fato uma disciplina na e ela só
começa a ser tratada como uma disciplina
de fato um campo de conhecimento foi
entre sarkozy e 18 e 19
mas as navegações começaram bem antes e
esse interesse de conhecer os povos
exóticos ditos primitivos é começou a
borbulhar na europa por causa dos
diários dos viajantes dos missionários
dos comerciantes porque esses diários de
viagem era na verdade muitas vezes
prestações de contas né
se a gente foi por exemplo olhar para o
brasil a carta de pero vaz caminha fala
muito do que ele viu né então eram
relatos e aí quando eles chegavam com
esses diários de viagem na europa é
outros profissionais da área de botânica
física astrofísica começaram a se
interessar por que diabo é isso como
eles são como que eles comem que eles
acreditam que rituais são esses né
porque se vestem dessa maneira ou não se
vestem e aí a surgiu uma espécie de é
interesse e aí a gente chama que são os
primeiros antropólogos que são aqueles
antropólogos guia de gabinete
eles estavam dentro das universidade e
aí passaram até outras outras dúvidas e
foi puxa é mas eu não tô com todas as
respostas em mãos
então aí que eu vou fazer eu vou até lá
não vou mandar o estagiário ea
estagiária ia para as tribos ea próprios
outros continentes fazer as perguntas
que não estavam respondidos nos diários
de viagem antropologia assim se forma
como um campo de conhecimento dentro das
ciências humanas
e aí a começa muito forte no final do
século 19 e início do século 20 onde os
antropólogos começam a se misturar e
assim vou ver naquele grupo que ele
tinha interesse em entender né
investigar e aí logo depois disso há a
gente começa a estudar a nós as nossas
tribos urbanas
a e aí o marco nessa área é o antônimo
sociólogos antropólogos chamado ele o
futuro haiti que escreve um livro
chamado sociedade de esquina
ele era um jovem estudante de chicago
que começa a ficar muito em dúvida e
muito curioso acerca das gangues
italianas que assolavam a chicago
e aí o que ele faz ele aluga uma um
quarto na casa de uma família ítalo
americana e se mistura com as pessoas
ele fica amigo de um das pessoas nas
grandes frequenta rua frequenta os
lugares para entender a lógica que
estava por trás das atitudes das acções
daquele lugar e viram uma espécie de
case de sucesso dentro da minha área e é
por isso que hoje por exemplo
desenvolver trabalhos dentro de uma
favela e isso desde 2011 eu estou lá no
meu terceiro endereço já vivendo e
convivendo dentro de uma favela de perto
e por dentro e aí logo depois no final
das cidadãs do java o século 21 no final
dos anos 70
essa forma de trabalhar de dentro de
perto ela começa a ser utilizado nas
indústrias nas empresas de uma forma
ainda muito iniciante inicial mas o
marco foi achar óxi em 1979 acharam que
estava com um problema grandioso porque
as pessoas não sabiam mexer na máquina e
aí eles não conseguiam vender a máquina
e aí que fizeram botaram antropólogos do
lado do sujeito que mexe na máquina e aí
eles perceberam que o problema estava no
painel monocromático então se hoje você
consegue tirar xerox fazer uma fotocópia
e aquele botão verde o botão vermelho
agradeçam antropólogos porque ele usou a
linguagem universal do pari e prossiga
então soluções às vezes muito simples
que o antropólogos tem essa percepção e
essa sensibilidade se colocar no lugar
do outro pra poder perceber as questões
que estão às vezes atrapalham
imagens nem às vezes é uma pedrinha é ea
gente tá lá pra resolver para tentar
entender
e aí o que acontece e aí eu vou falar do
meu case
eu era uma jovem formando na já estava
começando o primeiro mestrado e aí eu
fui uma entrevista de emprego numa
concessionária de energia elétrica e era
para a vaga de analista social ea
trabalhar com projetos sociais porque
quando se pensa em pessoas da minha área
sempre está ligada a questões
relacionadas à responsabilidade social
estava eu lá só que no seu diretor é
meio maluco e fez e ele me fez uma
pergunta é uma pergunta que foi o tom de
toda a nossa conversa na entrevista e
ele me fez a seguinte pergunta por que o
júri clientes fazem gato se imagina eu
pensei por que ele é diretor de uma
concessionária de energia elétrica não
sabe a resposta vou saber
é interessante pensar que dá tanto o
nome do gato depois eu descobri tem esse
nome por causa do rabo do gato que é
arqueado além do da idéia de gato gatuno
é trabalha na surdina nas escondidas
rouba né comida dos outros e distrital
mas o o fio é quando você fazer gato de
energia elétrica ele o principal meio o
mais comum é fazer um arquivamento de
fio de cobre para ligar na rede
então aí eu respondi que o problema todo
é que nós perdemos nós brasileiros 9
bilhões por ano com gasto de energia
elétrica
então é um problema que não consegue
conseguiram resolver até hoje e ele foi
me testar
e aí eu respondi não sei mas eu acho que
vocês também não sabe mas eu posso
tentar descobrir e aí ele ficou
encantado com isso e fui com essa menina
pretensiosa neve usada como assim
e aí eu falei olha na verdade essa é uma
pesquisa que você não pode fazer as
perguntas a e aí porque eu falei 'lógico
chega um cara lá do instituto de
pesquisa
minha senhora a senhora faz gato
o gato ali no ar condicionado
as pessoas vão dizer que não
aí eu como é que você espera que as
pessoas que respondam então antropólogos
ele não faz pergunta ele convive ele
participa ele observa ele entende as
regras tácitas o que está por trás das
ações das pessoas
e aí a eu contei pra ele contém vários
exemplos falei do fútil haiti falei de
uma série de outros antropólogos se
misturaram os índios yanomami é bob que
se misturaram com outros tribos
africanas e etc e tal companhia quis te
amo e aí todas as classificações e aí
ele me faz a segunda pergunta você
moraria na comunidade para tentar
descobrir
claro que eu não ia ser uma x 9 e eu
deixei isso muito claro por ética não é
por questões de ética mas ele queria
entender as motivações o quê porque
estava por trás das ações das pessoas
acir arquias de valor as motivações o
que é porque as pessoas fazem da maneira
que fazem e aí óbvio pouco você está
querendo um trabalho de fazer uma
pergunta dessa é a mesma coisa que
perguntar você venderia sua mãe dizendo
em 24 vezes
então assim eu disse moro
se vocês me deram todas as condições eu
moro e eu fui né
eu fui e é interessante que quando ele
usou a comunidade adoro falar isso a
comunidade é uma palavra politicamente
correta que diz que representa muita
coisa mas é vazio de significado né
e aí só que normalmente quando se fala
em comunidade da favela eu achei que eu
ia pra favela mas não era por isso que
deixei para o doutorado
mas aí eu fui para um bairro pobre um
bairro popular de classe trabalhadora é
que morava na sua grande parte o que é
chamada de nova classe média que é uma
categoria que eu detesto mas isso não
vem ao caso é papo de uma outra conversa
mas eu morei nesse nessa casa que na
verdade era uma espécie de cortiço onde
tinha 17
o meu era um deles mobiliei com os
móveis populares de loja de departamento
bem popular comprei roupas prade eu com
essa cara estrangeira de gringa
pra mim a ser melhor o máximo é com o
público né pra não criar muito atrito e
fui lá por oito meses ininterruptos
eu comi eu me divertir
eu frequentei salão de beleza eu fui na
padaria eu sentei na calçada eu convivi
com aquelas pessoas
eu entrei na casa das pessoas eu fui a
festas
ah eu fui a eventos da igreja de várias
a igreja católica igreja evangélica eu
queria entender por que isso
e aí é o que aconteceu eu descobrir que
a primeira coisa de tudo o que a gente
pensa quando é leigo e aí a idéia toda
ae quem faz gato é pobre né por
necessidade é um malandro e aí eu vi que
nós isso não é uma realidade que nem
sempre quem faz gato de energia elétrica
é pobre
nessa presa que me contratou 55 por
cento do índice de perdas que é aaa a
categoria que se que será utilizada é
55% é realizar algo de gato é realizado
por comércio indústria e camadas médias
e altas
e aí eu falei no e aí as casas e os
carros as viagens e fim eles fazem gato
porque porque o consumo é uma prática
cultural a gente tem que entender por
que as pessoas que cultura é essa quais
são as quais são esses valores que o que
movem as pessoas e as herarquias de
valores totalmente sócio culturais para
entender por que as pessoas escolhem
agir da maneira que agem e aí o seguinte
eu tava vi que estava dentro de uma
caixa preta e quando se pensa na
caixa-preta seplan bola logo no avião
nem avião né o que a caixa-preta venham
cá e vamos descobrir o que aconteceu
só que a caixa preta é tem um outro uma
outra a um outro conceito que é o do
bruno latour que caixa preta está ligado
à expressão em cibernética
tem uma máquina ou um conjunto de
comandos que se revela complexo demais
então eu vi que eu pra entender o que
acontecia eu precisava abrir essa caixa
preta
eu precisava entender como é que era o
mercado produtivo da energia elétrica
e como é que as pessoas entendiam esse
mercado percebiam a energia elétrica
e aí eu encontrei não uma caixa preta
mas encontrei duas uma a é da empresa
que não conhece os seus clientes
então um é o que eu percebi é que eles
não sabem quais são os valores
eles não sabem eles eles a eles não
sabem por que as pessoas agem de maneira
lógica eles têm métricas etc tal várias
estatísticas mas entender o que motiva
sócio culturalmente essas pessoas eles
não conhecem ea segunda caixa-preta é
própria do cliente que não tem idéia do
que significa energia elétrica porque a
energia elétrica é um bem e é um serviço
e ela não é natural
e aí eu apliquei 380 questionários neste
bairro que morei na região metropolitana
do rio
e eu perguntei de onde vem a energia
elétrica e as respostas foram incríveis
até foge iguaçu apareceu catarata vai da
catarata e vem ver vai do poste vem do
fio né então eles não entendem qual é o
mercado produtivo de geração transmissão
distribuição eles não têm idéia de
quanto isso custou zhu e ao mesmo tempo
a gente lida com a ideia de que puxa a
energia ou não pego né ela e você só
sente falta dela em dois momentos porque
é naturalizada vocês todos
no primeiro momento quando a conta de
luz chega em um segundo momento quando a
carência na falta de energia
então eu comecei a falar pô mas aí tudo
bem a empresa não tem estratégia de
combater o gato de resolver o problema
assim
inclusive existe até em certas empresas
uma espécie de lítio elite do corte de
fornecimento que eles chamam de cobras
heróis tipo bope
op dos eletricistas existe é e aí eu
falei pô mas eles estão combatendo mas
eles dependem do cliente não é coisa
meio louca a mas aí eles têm estratégias
mas o problema todo lá o corte pessoal
deixou no escuro
só que aí os clientes têm táticas
então eles desenvolvem estratégias mas
os clientes desenvolvendo táticas e aí a
gente precisa parar para pensar que
primeiro não é uma guerra
são dois grupos que dependem um do outro
para sobreviver 1 por causa da saúde da
empresa lucro manter funcionários e
outro por ter desde elétrica
e aí o que aconteceu eu tinha um desafio
porque seus clientes precisam fazer
táticas aonde está você nesse processo
onde está você empresa nesse processo e
aí o seguinte
aí eu fui entender a questão da energia
elétrica como bem o serviço
a energia é um produto só seu técnico
ou seja enquanto ela não for entendida
como um produto um bem ou serviço que
tem uma relação direta com a sociedade
e você precisa prestar atenção na
sociedade para saber como é que eles
utilizam energia como isso é utilizado
como isso é usufruído você nunca vai
entender o seu cliente
e aí uma vez que ela é um produto só se
o técnico está o tempo inteiro em
relação com relação às pessoas
ela é passível de uso e manipulação você
muda você resolve como você vai usar o
seu produto/serviço você tem liberdade
para isso
então a gente tem que mudar o olhar ea
primeiro passo é diferenciar dos
conceitos primeiro é esquecer desse
conceito de consumidor porque o
consumidor está passivo é uma ideia
passível de de tota passividade é o cara
que compra e consome a eu compro ao
consumo ao seu consumidor
agora o problema todo é que na nossa
sociedade essa essa imagem lá tem que
caducar porque nós somos usuários porque
nós tenhamos poder de manipulação
nós renovamos apropriamos e
reapropriados de bens e serviços nos
transformamos as coisas é é de acordo
com o nosso critério valorativo ea nossa
necessidade em situações cotidianas
diversas todos nós fazemos isso
então ao invés de ter estratégia como as
empresas normalmente fazem e as
estratégias
elas são a duras elas são inflexíveis
porque são muitas reuniões nem até
alguma coisa ser implementada é ela é
uma forma de dominação é uma ação é
forte
enquanto ela está lá naquele modo dentro
da caixa de pensar o usuário tá livre
leve solto para desenvolver a tática ea
tática é a criatividade é a
inventividade é a arte da viração a
tática é a arte do fraco esse usuário e
ele tem de ter poder de de manipulação e
resolver o problema dele independente da
empresa ele finge conformidade mas ele
só faz o que ele quer
o que é preciso ser feito então a gente
tem que entender que existe uma nova
ordem um novo paradigma
a gente precisa sair dessa história dos
quatro países para quem estudou
administração todos os as estratégias
são pensadas no preço promoção produto
praça e olhar mais para as pessoas e as
pessoas e como elas usam as coisas
os bens e os serviços porque essas
pessoas são imponderadas são complexas
segmentação de mercado complicado né
elas inovam e elas usam a tecnologia
elas desenvolvem a tecnologia delas e eu
vou dar um exemplo pra vocês
então é esse todo esse trabalho hoje que
a gente faz a gente precisa tomar como
premissa a conhecer o usuário tem que
ser o ponto de partida então como é que
a gente faz isso
a resposta está nas pessoas o que elas
fazem é o que elas se paulão é o que
elas pensam eo que elas sentem e como é
que eu descubro isso não é fazendo
a luta porque uma hora que você faz a
pergunta às pessoas racionalizam e aí
você vai construir respostas racionais
né
e aí o seguinte ao invés de entender o
consumidor eu tenho que entender as
pessoas então todas as relações que nós
estabeleçamos a gente é são relações
sócio técnicas
então a sociedade mas tecnologia a gente
tem os usos e contra o uso
então vou dar um exemplo pra que serve
uma bic vai falar pra escrever
quem tem cabelo cumprido vai saber que
babi que serve pra prender o cabelo abic
serve para salvar uma vida pra matar
alguém pra brincar tem gente que pinta o
cabelo com a tinta fazer tatuagem então
tá entidade para quem tem mais de 30
anos sabe que servia para enrolar fita
cassete
então quem nunca customizou dar toda um
jeitinho quem lembra do magaiver magar
ver o rei da gambiarra e eu digo que não
é gambiarra rearranjo técnico porque tem
expertise essa história da máquina de
lavar funciona eu já fiz lá em casa
festinha deu certo a e aí você tem
outros exemplos mais comuns os
aplicativos isso aqui tudo saiu de
semana passada na mídia
o team df é um aplicativo de pegação
passou a ser para encontrar pessoas
desaparecidas na a mãe cria pp bloquear
o celular dos filhos que não querem
atender aos seus telefonemas que a mãe
normalmente é chato e aí o seguinte é
porque meus clientes fazem gato essa
pergunta não respondo porque vale um
milhão de dólares porque os clientes não
comprou meu produto etc e tal para tudo
há a resposta está nas pessoas
então vamos olhar as pessoas né é isso
obrigada gente